the capacity or no that the the tendency
to accept evolutionary theory is of
course not just judged on the merits of
evolutionary theory it's judged because
it is seen as being in opposition to
religious belief and religious belief
carries with it not just the belief
itself in a particular set of facts and
ideas but all of the huge social and
political I associations so in in the
United States if you don't believe in
evolutionary theory or if you do believe
in evolutionary theory then it means
it's harder for you to commit yourself
to a religious group that has huge
significance and so I think the answer
to why it is that evolutionary theory is
difficult for people in the States to
believe is that religious systems are so
incredibly prevalent and why is that I
guess I think it's something to do with
the United States being a rural country
and there's a lot of association between
rural living and the importance of
religious systems you see it in the
Middle East you see it in Iran I suspect
that as the world becomes more urbanized
you know we've just passed the point
where 50% of the world's population live
in cities I think as this tendency
increases probably the importance of
religious belief systems will start
declining or will continue to decline
and that one of the consequences will be
that there will be increasing
willingness to accept even those aspects
of science that challenge religious
belief